so the last segment we heard about a
hypothetical about selling embryos and I
asked you to tell me what you think well
now we're gonna hear a little bit about
what my students think now that we've
discussed a little bit about
hypotheticals in this area we're gonna
really delve in to better understand
what are the moral limits of the market
what things
shorter should not be sold so today
we're gonna be joined by a bunch of my
students we're gonna tell you a little
bit of what they think about these
issues I'm Quillan Luke I'm Tori I'm
Dorothy and I'm Nate let's start with a
list of things that in a just society
people debate whether they should or
should not be sold and you've often
heard these discussed probably in the
media these are things like surrogacy
sperm eggs babies kidneys ICU beds votes
Nobel Prizes sexual services I'm
thinking about prostitution and the
ability or the obligation to serve in
the military so I'm going to start by
asking my students to pick one of these
that they think shouldn't be sold and
we'll hear what they think okay so who
wants to start who can tell me how it's
something on this list that you think
shouldn't be sold yeah please
I don't think Nobel Prizes should be
sold okay because doing so I think would
take away the inherent value that we put
the idea is that a nobel prize has a
certain value what's that value like I
think the value is that it comes from
merit so if somebody wants a Nobel Prize
it's because we think that they deserve
it and if they're able to buy or sell it
then that takes away the merit exactly
so the idea is that a good has a certain
value certain social meaning and we
might corrupt that social meaning by
making it viable or sellable who can
take another one on the list and give me
an argument why they think it shouldn't
be sold yeah I don't think ICU beds
should be sold great so why shouldn't
ICU beds be sold I would be concerned
about whether the bed to be available
for the people who actually need them if
they're being sold to the highest seller
or bidder great so you're concerned with
the distribution and the claim is that
there would be an unfair distribution of
the good if we allowed it to be sold it
would be
sold and allocated based on ability to
pay rather than based on a more moral
form of allocation excellent
anyone else have one they want to pick
out please Luke yes I'd be very
concerned about votes being sold and why
would you be concerned about votes being
sold that seems like it would open the
door to corruption in the democratic
process where whoever you know had the
money to buy an election essentially
good so kind of an externalize costs
right an externality here but also a
corruption of the meaning of the good a
vote is meant to be a registering of
one's preference or one's belief in a
candidate but instead it would become a
chip to be traded it and that would
corrupt the way in which we think
elections ought to be handled other ones
what about prostitution for example I
was actually going to talk about babies
I don't feel comfortable with selling
babies both because of the sense of kind
of monetizing a baby it seems difficult
to swallow and also it would create a
situation where people who can pay for
babies would then have the babies and
and that doesn't seem like that's the
way that we want to allocate the who
gets to have babies in our society so
one perspective is that it would corrupt
the social meaning of how a child is
valued a child should be valued not as a
commodity but something else the other
claim is worn about unfair allocation
and distribution but focusing on babies
again are there any other kinds of
objections they might have to the buying
and selling of babies do we worry about
exploitation for example is anybody
worried about that when it comes to
babies please well I would be worried
that the babies that are bought and sold
would be different than in like an on
market scenario and what babies were
most desirable would be different from
the babies who are available for
adoption now excellent so the idea would
be a market for babies might attach
certain values some babies would be
worth more than others you might say
that's a kind of eugenic concern right a
concern about valuing people based on
their traits and going for kind of
perfectionism rather than giving them
the kind of respect they're due merely
as a person what about prostitution is
to return to this example for a moment
what if anything is wrong with
prostitution yeah I would be concerned
with prostitution that poor woman would
be forced into it because they have no
other alter
economically and that would seem wrong
excellent right so the idea that the
seller a lot of these objections that
we've talked about so far have focused
on the good itself it's being corrupted
it's being unfairly allocated now we've
shifted our focus to look a little bit
more at the seller and the idea is that
the seller is being wronged or harmed in
such a way and in your mind is this
about exploitation is it about coercion
is it about undue inducement tell me a
little bit more about what you are
afraid of in the situation I think it's
both coercion and exploitation I think
that a circumstance could arise where a
woman would be forced into prostitution
because a deal is too good for her she
could be paid too much in the
alternative it could be that a woman
needs money and therefore will accept a
very low amount of money to be a
prostitute so their concern about too
low amount of money is a little bit
about exploitation right she's paying
too little when you're talking about
being paid too much for thinking a
little bit more about undue inducement
we're kind of overcoming her sense of
what her desires are or should be yeah
you wanted something I just wanted to
say that as we think about the
prostitution shifting the focus to the
seller I also wonder whether there's the
potential that there's actually somebody
else selling the we're saying woman here
it couldn't there be a man as well into
prostitution so that's to say that the
person who's entering into prostitution
could actually be simply the commodity
as opposed to also being the seller and
the idea here would be that there's
someone like a pimp right it was pushing
them and that may be a little bit more
like coercion right someone else forcing
them to do something that may not be in
their interests
what about surrogacy right so this is
something we'll actually talk about the
course and all the things you've said
all these arguments we'll see shortly
are perfectly applicable in this context
as well but what about surrogacy
specifically if you think about
surrogacy what worries you about a
market for surrogacy in the United
States in many states we permit people
to sell surrogacy services elsewhere in
the world that's a big no-no in much of
Europe that's forbidden is there
anything that concerns you about selling
surrogacy services I think I would be
concerned with like rights that the
seller has I guess there's different
kinds of surrogacy if you're like
biologically related to the child or if
you're
biologically related and what rights you
have as the gestational carrier with
regards to the child after they're born
or even like with regards to actions you
take for your health while you're
carrying the child so the concern here
is that being in a market relationship
might alter the way in which you think
about your relationship to the child
right one famous article suggests that
we're asking women to basically repress
their feelings of maternal attachment
and love for the child they're gestating
and instead but you also suggested that
may alter your behavior in ways that are
different that if you're carrying your
own child
you might behave in one way whereas if
you're carrying for profit you might
behave in a different yeah please with
respect to surrogacy you might think
that putting a price tag on this service
would actually cause some people to
react negatively to it and not want to
participate in the process or exactly
right so the idea is we currently have a
certain distribution a certain level of
the good or service provided when you
attach a price tag to it there's a
concern that you might crowd out people
right people might be turned off it's
annoying it's for sale and therefore no
longer provided in this case the idea is
we've got a pool of altruistic surrogacy
going on and the concern is that there
may be individuals that if we allow it
for sale surrogacy that would no longer
participate yeah and also I think that
it would create a situation where people
would have a reason to kind of look out
and rule over in a way the autonomy of
other people because for this nine
months the person with the long term
interest and the child is not the person
making the short-term interest that
would affect the child yeah so one way
of characterizing this many ways of
characterizing that point one way is to
say that you thinks this woman was
making a decision to be a surrogate
she's being short-sighted right she
thinks she knows what she's getting into
but she doesn't and this is a concern
about justified paternalism right the
idea is that we need to help her not
make a bad choice and for that reason
we're gonna prohibit the buying and
selling of the good although notice that
that objection might say well isn't that
true of altruistic surrogacy as well
maybe we should forbid all of surrogacy
well now that you've heard from my
students about the kinds of objections
that pee
might raise to the buying and selling of
a number of the goods and services
including those relevant to this course
now going to take a step back and look
at those objections a little more
formally